es geht um rente in der tat ist ein
thema was mich emotionalisiert kann man
ein wenig witze drüber machen eigentlich
aber es ist trotzdem ein noch bin ich
extrem wichtiges thema ist der teuerste
dauerbrenner dienst in deutschland gibt
es ist das thema rente und interessant
ist dass wir mitten im wahlkampf sind
und die meisten parteien über dieses
thema überhaupt nicht sprechen obwohl es
der größte kostenblock ist im
bundeshaushalt über 100 milliarden gehen
mittlerweile pro jahr in die rentenkasse
insgesamt zahlt die rentenkasse und 325
milliarden euro aus aber die parteien
nehmen das thema gar nicht richtig auf
stattdessen verstecken sie kleine
botschaften in ihrem wahlprogramm als
wenn es ihnen peinlich wäre und am ende
geht es eigentlich eigentlich nur um
kosten es geht darum wie teuer wird die
rente für uns alle künftig werden es
gibt programme da geht daraus hervor
dass die rente deutlich teurer noch
werden wird das noch mehr geld in die
rentenkasse fließen muss aber niemand
spricht über diese kosten ich glaube
deswegen es ist allerhöchste zeit für
die parteien uns vor allem den menschen
50 also der unter 50 jährigen zu sagen
dass wir alle bis 70 mindestens arbeiten
müssen denn anders lässt sich das
rentensystem in deutschland nicht mehr
finanzieren auskommen die sicht ist
schon rente wird im wahlkampf
totgeschwiegen könnte schon gestern hab
ich gemacht ja es gefällt mir sehr gut
ich will mich immer wenn ja wenn da
steht rentner in den druck im wahlkampf
totgeschwiegen dann haben wir noch mehr
gäste ihren lieblingswitz präsentiert
wäre es auch ein renner gewesen
waren oli pocher in rente da nicht
wahrscheinlich ja bei mir ist das so wir
machen das ja mir macht das ja spaß
grundsätzlich ich bin auch ehrlich
gesagt jemand der nicht wirklich in das
gesetzliche rentensystem einzahlt gibt
in bei manchen jobs aber man
zwangsläufig ein zahlt also gerade so
bei schauspiel box da gibt es die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung sogar
auch mal neulich in anspruch gelesen
irgendwie den ich habe ich glaube
aktuell klick 3 400 euro im monat aber
als renten thema gibt es das gar nicht
und wird kurz vor der sendung ich gesagt
ich habe zum beispiel ein renten plakat
gesehen von der linkspartei da stand da
war an absurdität nicht zu überbieten
war es steht halt renten rentenalter
runter und renten drauf aber es ist kein
echtes das war von oli pocher das plakat
das war wirklich von der linkspartei ich
jetzt ich kann es gerne raussuchen oder
abfotografieren also sonneborn wo man
sich denkt ja man das wirklich links hat
wo man denkt man müsste mit
60 in die rente und dann kriegt jeder
2000 euro weil können wir so machen und
das rentensystem ist so ja schon gar
nicht mehr zu halten das weiß jeder aber
das ist wie mit umwelt und es kommen
einige echt unangenehme themen wir haben
ja hier über gender sprache gesprochen
aber ich finde thema rente thema umwelt
thema ganz viel die viel wichtiger in
viel brennender sind und auch in diesem
wahlkampf natürlich komplett zu kurz
kommen
so viele investoren das finde ich sehr
bewundernswert mir ja gerne auf
innsbruck lange schön weil ich immer
finde das ist toll ist wie du frauen
vermittelt dass sie selbst für sich
sorgen müssen finanz sehr stark sein und
du bist ja auch investorin es ist auch
schon eine form von der lenden
absicherung für später natürlich mal
investiert ja nicht einfach nur
lust und laune sondern man spekuliert er
darauf dass ich davon irgendwann mal ne
gute auszahlung bekommt man natürlich
das ist natürlich ein bisschen wie ihr
das ist es ist halt sehr bodenständig in
etwas das zu investieren was auch noch
mit bau und stuttgart zu tun hat
genau und ja klar ich habe auch eine
rentenversicherung habe ich auch und ich
habe überhaupt aber ja ich habe ich
figur in sofias beispiel sieht man was
die politik falsch machen du hast ja
auch mal angela merkel getroffen ja und
ich finde bei dir ich finde du bist ein
vorbild davon für eine frau sorgt für
dich selbst die politiker sind ich habe
viel zu wenig das thema rente viel zu
wenig die inhalte der rente findet
ehrlich gesagt nicht gedacht aber wir
wissen dass wir überhaupt irgendwelche
themen statt aktuell also das ist sehr
überschaubar gewichtige fragen an thema
aber nach ist das die erste der
bundeshaushalt besteht zu mindestens
einem viertel das hängt natürlich davon
ab wie viel geld geht es gerade wer
panahi wird wir waren schon dabei dass
ein drittel des bundeshaushaltes in die
rentenkasse ließ das heißt da ist ja den
politikern auch jede möglichkeit
genommen mit dem restlichen geld noch
irgendwas zu tun wenn schon ein so
großer batzen weg geht und er wird in
den nächsten jahren eher noch größer
während berichte und alle drücken sich
um die lösung dieses problems oder so
ist die lösung die lösung des problems
kann ja nur sein wenn man den den die
rente nicht weiter absenken will das
rentenniveau oder auch die beitragssätze
die die beschäftigten bezahlen wenn ich
unbedingt sehr stark steigern möchte
dass dass wir alle länger arbeiten
müssen das ganz klar ein bundesbürger
lebt heute im schnitt noch 20 jahre nach
hinten beginnen das war in den 60er
jahren hat er ungefähr zehn jahre rente
bezogen also er bezieht mittlerweile
doppelt so lange rente geht aber nur ein
ganz klein bisschen später in rente als
noch in den 60ern und das kann nicht
funktionieren
es ist sozusagen rente das renten thema
ist glaube ich das thema in dem das
versagen der politik am deutlichsten
wird politik soll ja immer auch vorsorge
sein und voraussicht und die menschen in
eine gesellschaft auf einzustellen was
kommt das wird einfach so verschwiegen
wie verschwiegen worden ist dass in
afghanistan im krieg ist wie
verschwiegen worden ist dass wir große
lücken haben in unserem alarmsystem wenn
umweltkatastrophen passieren und so
weiter das hängt glaube ich alles damit
zusammen dass politiker vergessen haben
dass sie dafür da sind den menschen
ehrlich gegenüber zu treten und was wir
hier gerade sprechen mit der frage
vorsorge hört sich ja für die meisten
menschen wahrscheinlich total verrückt
an weil sie gar kein geld haben dass sie
irgendwas investieren könnten und auf
die gesetzliche rente angewiesen sind
die ihnen dann sozusagen
wegschmilzt ich glaube dass hier grad
für war schon ganz kleine möglichkeiten
ganz klein gelb naja jetzt empfehlen
aber es gibt manchmal wenn ich überlege
ich glaube wenn wir ein tipi koch
richtig
ich glaube wenn du keine ahnung
400 300 euro freies budget wenn monat
hast dann dann denkst du gar nicht was
kann ich jetzt eigentlich auch für die
private vorsorge zurückging ist die
größte verlogenheit der politik das ist
ja genau das ist und wie norbert blüm
der legendäre dem älteren unter uns auch
jüngere die rente ist sicher war die
grösste populistische lüge die es jemals
gab absolut das ist ja unehrlichkeit auf
mit doppeltem boden zum einen gaukelt
man jenen die jetzt noch vorsorgen
könnten auch wenn es schwerfällt und
wenn es vielleicht nur fünf euro oder
zehn euro im monat sind ja vor alles ist
in ordnung das bittere ende kommt ja
irgendwann diese menschen werden
irgendwann auch in die rente gehen wenn
irgendwann 67 sein und stellen dann fest
wo es reicht gar nicht so richtig zum
leben mensch hätte mir doch mal jemand
mit 50 oder mit 55 gesagt dass ich noch
etwas zur seite legen muss und der
zweite punkt ist wenn man das thema
nachhaltigkeit sprechen wir sehen das ja
eben wieder klima klima nachhaltigkeit
grad die grünen schien das thema ja nun
massiv vor sich ja wo ist denn
eigentlich die nachhaltigkeit bei den
staatsfinanzen wo ist denn eigentlich
nachhaltigkeit bei den renten finanzen
das würde ich mir bei einer partei die
die nachhaltigkeit so groß auf die
fahnen schreibt eigentlich wünschen dass
sie da ehrlich ist und sagt meine pläne
unsere pläne die werden richtig teuer
faust bitterer kommen die sich kann ich
sagen will wenn wir den klimawandel
verpacken brauchen wir die renten nicht
mehr von daher mit diesen baulichen
wenig erbaulichen kommen sie gut durch
den 8
poker ist sagen wir hier chips aus der
runde immer wieder für sie da
[Musik]